[Music]
welcome to the family hacksaw
hey oh hey georgie
you okay mm-hmm
you sure not really um
dustin broke up with me
what i mean he said i was immature
is he crazy everything about you screams
[Music]
womanhood
hey hi i was wondering if you wanted to
grab a bite to eat at the waffle house
not like a date but as someone who
recently had his heart broke
i think i could help who broke your
heart
i love you
you did oh yeah
i'm just saying i know what you're going
through
so if you need a friend with a pocket
full of waffle money
i thought dustin was different i thought
he wanted to live a christian life like
me but
all he wanted is what every guy wants
guys please you're all the same
hey you rejected me you punched me in
the face
and i'm still happy eating waffles with
you
georgie do you really think you're
capable of just being my friend
that's a good question my brain says yes
what about the rest of you honestly i
wouldn't trust it
i know it's tough but you got to be
strong remember
you're not alone hello
kind of busy well there's only one
bathroom in the house georgie and it's
not for phone calls
i got to call you back sorry
who are you talking to that veronica
girl
yeah what's going on with it nothing
we're just friends
okay hey you everyone running this stuff
by me
i'm here for you why would i want to run
about you
well i was once a 15 year old boy i know
what it's like to have
strong feelings for a girl gross i'm not
gonna talk to you about this
i i saw that kid on who's the boss
talked to tony dance about his problem
they're not related this is totally
different
damn it georgia you can flush once in a
while
[Music]
mind if i see it you sure you want to be
seen with me
oh please you're not a commie
everyone else seems to think i am do you
even know what a communist
is yeah it's the big blond guy rocky
fights in rocky
iv and he also finds him when he's rambo
that's it well i know in every movie it
looks like the commies are going to win
but they don't you ever seen any rocky
movies
uh i saw rocky too that's the second one
[Music]
you